okay now we'll we'll talk about the Ken
in
down
if you feel your cheeks or any part of
your body under tension like the hamster
cheeks even if they're not blown out
like hamster cheeks
that you can feel tension then you've
got it wrong your breath is not going to
be efficient
the breath needs to come in
go down
we're tying it but as a as if your body
is a strong canister
strong canister
holding this in but not under stress
start the breath coming in before the
action of lifting the can
start the out breath before the action
of the Ken
again I won't make a loud key I
but
add the key eye but get the Rhythm if
you start feeling dizzy you've been
breathing more than you need to
your quantity is taking in too much
you shouldn't feel dizzy blurred vision
or anything it should be comfortable it
should be the amount you need for the
cut that you you perform
in fast
momentarily after lift the cane breathe
out momentarily after cut
oh
Ken starts to move
at the key I don't put the key eye in
before the Ken moves
hey
I
okay so it's slightly update slightly
before slightly after
hey
that was the key I before the can
started and it'll be like a drag and you
won't have power in the cut the cut will
be The Swinging of the arms very slight
you may not have seen it I'll do it
again
hey
I delayed it more that time so this is
incorrect
in breath
action
out with action key eye
hey
I'm now the can I'm going to try and
come close so
start the breath mum till now after left
the can
open the mouth
start the breath
start the can
add the key I
you don't need to see the cut I'm going
to just try it you'll see it but I'm
going to try to make it so that you can
be close enough to
foreign
something that you may not have known
before
or it shows you the detail that you need
once you do that and you've got the
Rhythm then your cut will work naturally
but it's not going to come in a day a
week a month a year it'll take years but
you'll get it the more you practice like
anything
hey
[Music]